-Our next guests are nominated
for two Grammys,
including Best Rock Album.
Performing "The Wheel"
from their album "Crawler,"
give it up for Idles.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One, two,
one, two, three, four!
♪♪
♪ I got on my knees ♪
♪ And I begged my mother ♪
♪ With the bottle in one hand ♪
♪ It's one or the other ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
♪ Again and again ♪
♪ She woke from a slumber ♪
♪ With a crippled stance ♪
♪ She said she missed
my brother ♪
♪ And wanted one more chance ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
♪ Again and again ♪
♪ The wheel ♪
♪ Turn ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
Hoo!
♪ Can I get a hallelujah? ♪
♪ Hear it from the back now ♪
Hey!
♪♪
♪ So, I put up a poster ♪
♪ Saying where's my dog ♪
♪ My friends, my family,
my job ♪
♪ Nobody turned back now ♪
♪ Except for my man ♪
♪ With a mournful pious grin ♪
♪ And a bag in his hand ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
♪ Again and again ♪
♪ Then the seagulls found me ♪
♪ I couldn't tell what year ♪
♪ But with no one around me ♪
♪ The motion was clear ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
♪ Again and again ♪
♪ The wheel ♪
♪ And so it turns ♪
♪♪
Yeah!
♪ Can I get a hallelujah? ♪
♪ Hear it from the back ♪
♪ Hear it from the back now ♪
♪ Can I get a hallelujah? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]